per la bella dei capelli e la a tutti
ragazzi e benvenute questo novello sono
fa vj in questa puntata ragazzi volevo
alternare due che sono state tra le
serie con più successo durante l'estate
google film vieider l'on
iniziamo con di aiger la quale è più
famoso tra arcieria abroad church
algeria partenza pop di merda perfetto
un minuto di silenzio tutti quanti per
la scritta di google fugees che non mi
ha caricato
manco per il cazzo questo gameplay avrà
la scritta sbanca pazienza ad accordare
che sony era da un po che non lo facevo
google fumetti o matthew mac mekong e
quello lì back come cazzo si scrive
becon ag e nicchia come lo scritto e ciò
a storo ci credo era giusto veramente
era giusto metti un mercoledì scritto
che ho scritto alla cazzo va bene
d'addario con la mano ricordar avevo le
mono ne conosco mango 1 matthew di pai
fa vj facciamo nomi ragazzi che me la
cavo
barbara barbara
non ce la posso fare a scriverlo stresa
ma ha messo a barbara ne conosco una
neanche mezza torniamo su d hiver lower
ragazzi allora pluto o red nose day un
brutto penso
red nose day perché c'è un giorno
dedicato al naso rosso abraham lincoln
ok a prali a quest'ora general motors
ragazzi non mi ricordo matera mera tipo
milioni 7 milioni e mezzo a caso general
motors e aurora general motors perché la
gente interessa più dei motori che
dell'aurora aurora o michael bay michael
bay non se lo incula nessuno porca eva
esplodi no nel senso che fa le
esplosioni a eni david homework stavo
già fatto uso scritto
[Musica]
matera già matematica o fatta meglio la
prima volta che non la sapevo va beh
harry potter contro tette mi dispiace mi
dispiace piuttosto mi masturbo su harry
potter sono serie brees o ruote rail
briest autismo squali squali da autismo
porca eva non rischia fancazzo oggi
cultura le giraffe sono delle cattive
persone
no sono animali sono title creature
senza cuore sorge le giraffe sono gay
sono non sinceri fantastico io amo le
giraffe meravigliosa questa risposta
stupide alieni fake creature crudeli
erbivori o selfish com'è che di tutte
queste dieci solo erbivori ha un senso e
tutte le altre sono puttanate spiegatevi
portorico milano milano milano milione
836 gran cazzi milano churchill milano
per forza churchill oikia ikea
secondo match avrà tra le 13 20 milioni
porcaccia la trova chi che house rules
and who am i fatti più mai [ __ ]
l'altra volta a fan culo se ruolo kim
kardashian kim kardashian avrà quindi
cacciava kardashian olimpiadi minchia
questa era la giocano kim kardashian
viene infatti quel the roman ibu cup
guai
quello lì manny bene chi cazzo è un ex
pugile politico filippino sì perché io
lo sapevo ma anni per guaio è che quello
lì ed è powerpuff girls quindi le
superchicche secondo me
manny perché non sarei in cura più
nessuno le guardavo io da piccolo e
basta tra inception e thailandia
thailandia
vai così forte vai così thailandia e
justin justin bieber avrà almeno 15
spero se kim kardashian ne ha 11 credo
13 beh quasi nuovo anno cinese justin
bieber ei dei lords di pochissimo che
culo
peterhansel già catching payday lance
che al cinema che cosa vuol dire ciò che
ci da imi che era arrivata 21 che record
stavo facendo ora grazie va dal tipo
grazie vado molto meglio su d hiver
lover che su google feud prova la
biografia di fa vigenza di greta menchi
non trova un cazzo donald trump era il
primo my friend is addicted to burn no
pon pon
ecco ma pokémon pokémon [ __ ] sono
me c'era o psico tina instagram che va
più dei pochi i miei piedi odorano come
parmigiano c era il primo pack e
parmigiano ad air force un cavallo morto
non è quello sanno rifritto sanno di
morte sanno vigorito di merda di di erba
di piscio di gatto albert einstein
migliore 500 contro hp che ne avrà 17 2
milioni solo pensavo molto di più a
capire beauty salon hp
ok vai vai vai che suo carico stavolta
il record è elettricista elettricista
veloce veloce tesco avrà miliardi questo
non so perché infatti vai vai vai vai
così vai così carico
kobe bryant copy perché dovrei farlo vi
sessuale o dio justin bieber ricordo che
ne ha 13 e mezzo e quindi ne ha tipo 13
17 volte più di dio e a mariah carrey
questa venus di almeno 7 no il resto
l'intero corso non so devo solo justin
bieber na così tanti minchia incredibile
clarinetto ed ashley madison ashley
madison tutta la vita slim edinson
magari era una roba porno e ho appena
fatto una figura di merda
ashley madison hotel 5 stelle ashley
madison ok perfetto hotel 5 stelle nba
nicchia figure zambia marca e la nba ed
sheeran quei 5 milioni cini e li voglio
5 mi deludi caro janet jackson ed
sheeran comunque è neanche di troppo
janet jackson e jose mourinho jose
mourinho
sicurissimo che aaron parks singapore è
infatti o 17 era gara 17 fino a bangkok
cercando aaron swartz bangkok o terra
bangkok
[ __ ] non credo che qualcuno
cercasse terra era troppo scontato
everything face bad tutto ha un sapore
di merda tutto ha un sapore di buono
tuttomerda rende il migliore o i
migliori i migliori condom mica se c'era
best guild of the best dressed niente
kratom ma che cazzo è un creatore ha
creato non significa pelle chi vende le
migliori biginsights potato sala di
hajar lo era allora guan direction 6
milioni 7 otto e mezzo quattro mi chiama
ragazzi vabbè disney di più sicuro sono
a partito sono partito me ne frega
niente sono partito sono partito vai vai
vai vai vai vai continua continua
continua emotiva a suo carico
ateismo ateismo
perché voglio capire bene nuovi saperi
l'hanno mica perché sempre milano oggi
che succede milano arcieri arcieri hano
vittoria force bye bye bye carico le
vittoria fall sporca e va ai ragazzi
facciamo le ultime due una di google
chiude una di di aicarr lover e poi
basta
cosa succede se metti nel microonde abb
ad occhi aperti
un animale domestico un cazzo un gatto
ha vergato sì ma al cane no nutella
io ci ho provato tante volte nay phone
perché ultima di aicarr lover ci siamo
bayern monaco contro cerci il bayern
monaco è la prima è andata
rafael nadal coi due o tre milioni
celiani ok skrillex rafael nadal contro
skrillex skrillex celia quel milione e
mezzo no skrillex contro beyoncé qua mi
dispiace vincevi un serio se contro
depressione brevi holmes e guy pitt coin
depressione a cazzo non credeva l'avesse
così tanti bitcoin vabbè 7 tanto di
sette non potevo fare coincidenze quindi
la casuali questi sono stati di tiger 9
re google chirurgiche sono fantastici ma
che sia stato portato un sacco di
gameplay strani però volevo chiudere
questa cerchia di either lover google
feud poiché avanti quando lo
aggiorneranno li farà ovviamente di
nuovo spero che avete voi siete 100
ragazzi in cosa mi è piaciuto
l'argomento è un mi piace anche a
facendo i facebook come di dotare
descrizione cesare cities cattolici
vediamo il proprio video e ragazzi